hello hi and welcome my name is Rob
Handlery and this is gam spots now
playing today we're taking a look at
space engineers but with a special treat
I have with me in game via
Skype the lead artist Tomas fampus how
you doing you there U I'm doing great
hello and I just logged off for a second
there doing great awesome and also the
um another artist here
um Adam hello hello pronounced it
correctly great so uh yeah we are here
in um just a standard creative match and
these guys um are going to give us uh
just a rundown on some upcoming features
for this early access game uh currently
on Steam it's the fourth top selling
game at the moment it's an absolute
blast I've been playing it lately and
since last December there have been
significant changes and uh a lot more to
come yep so so who's pink that's me
that's I him hi
hi all right so yeah you guys just want
to walk me through some um of the newest
stuff yeah sure if you want to start
with the latest update if you want okay
uh well like do you mean the one that is
coming or the one that was this time uh
how about um so what's like one of the
newest so I know one of the most recent
stuff um add add-ons was the the ability
to make faction as in as factions as in
your own kind of Clan or group uh which
is what we did here if I pull up the
menu go to factions and here we are this
is a group now I played yesterday and
there's a bunch of other uh factions
that you can see on a um any given
survival um server and the coolest thing
is you can click on one of those guys
and either propose piece or declare
war so how how's that been uh working
out as far as uh servers I haven't seen
any um massive battles going but have
you guys seen any
um of uh battles
yourselves can go ahead uh I've seen
quite a few battles that people have
been setting up yeah and the factions
allows people to sort of uh come
together and group up their stuff uh
sort of more officially rather than
people just claiming their uh ships and
their stations Etc they can actually
officially uh claim them and then they
can do War properly because one of the
uh main features of factions is the
ability to claim all the blocks of
certain things so as you'll notice
everything's made up of different blocks
and modules and before things like
turrets on the larger ships would only
engage people would engage any everyone
and anyone that you told them too where
so with factions we add a um system
whereby people could uh set the their
ships to their own faction and then any
other faction ships that came near
within range of the turrets would be
engaged so it allowed people to sort of
battle properly uh through the meaning
of through the means of factions that's
that's right because I remember one of
the last times I played there were
simply turrets that I'm looking at over
here they're like Auto turrets but they
didn't seem to really shoot anything
other than asteroids that would um come
at you whoa you took off quick and um
asteroids and then of course there's
like a a decoy um item you can throw and
they'll shoot at that but now that
totally makes sense that uh these
turrets now have a significant p uh
purpose of shooting an uh an enemy
faction that's great yeah they they also
Target the the important parts of the
ships so they'll start with thrusters
and like try to find the uh reactors and
stuff like that so they don't shoot
anything that moves but only the the
important parts yeah can you can you set
uh or inform or I mean I guess program
the turrets to shoot at uh specific
areas uh currently no but that's one of
the things we're going to be working on
is the ability to sort of take control
of the turrets uh remote controlling uh
by remote sorry and then you can uh fire
them yourselves or fire groups of them
specific
areas sweet uh so yeah you guys just
want to kind of show me um maybe some
upcoming stuff you have been working
on okay so um we got a list here of the
things that uh we are going to be adding
this sort of an exclusive thing uh one
of the big things that we're going to be
adding in I think it's next week's
update is the um addition of
Pistons so that will allow for a lot
more mechanical things to be
made we already made some testing and it
should be much easier to make like
hanger doors and stuff like that or or
so turrets that can be uh like put
outside uh covered territory so it it
won't take such a long time as before or
until now and more players will be able
to build like more um complex ships with
actually um like proper hanger doors and
stuff like that yeah so there'll be um
pistons for large and small ships and on
the large ship they will be 2x twox one
2X one by one which is like this giant
pillar built over here so the red bit
will be the actual pillar the actual
piston block will be the red bit and
then it can extend up to five blocks
upwards depending on what you set it Etc
it'll have all the same settings as
rotors so you can set the power and the
speed of the acceleration and stuff
gotcha that's
awesome very cool
mhm Al also in this uh update uh there
will be
batteries many people were asking for
Batteries since the solar panels were
yeah yeah since the solar panels well
introduced and they should be pretty
cool because now you will have much more
power over how to actually work with
electricity and how to make stations and
um actually make battery modules to like
Place between shapes and stuff like that
we tried a few Concepts where you can
actually attach small ship batteries to
large grid so that means that you can
kind of like have a large reactor that
is uh covered with uh connectors and
then you can connect these modules to
the connectors and actually charge the
batteries and then when they are uh
charged you can just fly close take them
with merge blocks and then fly away and
use them instead of uh like regular
reactors and stuff like that that's
awesome yeah and just for anyone who
doesn't know the basically the main way
of powering uh any kind of device is uh
with uranium which you have to to mine
for so that's kind of like the almost
like kind of the end game of like being
self sustaining with you know sunlight I
suppose right yeah well it takes a while
actually to charge a battery oh it
does uh you will have to have quite a
large um solar panel station to to kind
of um charge batteries uh quite quickly
but um it could be something as you said
the end end game uh end game thing where
you don't have to mine any uranium
anymore you can just uh stick up with
with the batteries and solar energy so
right or at least slow down because that
was something I was playing like even
last night it was just like you get kind
of caught up in some kind of um you know
build or process and you realize oh I
have no more uranium and I you got to
then drop everything just to hunt that
down so this would be some way of yeah
definitely slowing that process that's
cool we're also going to be boosting the
um output and the output of solar panels
are going to be boosting it so they
produce I think it's uh 15 times more
power than they do currently cuz people
have been saying it's a little low so we
had a sit down the other day and we sort
of talked through the um how much power
we think they should uh give out if
they're at full charge and we're also
going to be um reducing the amount of
materials that it takes to build a solar
panel to make them sort of more viable
power options yeah I currently haven't
even built a a solar p solar panel and
that's that takes a while you uh people
have been saying
yeah before the they talk about I think
it was like 2 and a half minutes to weld
one of them so that's a little extreme
so that
down actually we kind of uh looked into
the way the solar panels the solar
panels work and we kind of optimized it
so they should be more accessible right
now it shouldn't be that hard anymore to
actually build a solar panel I see cool
well um
heck is there anything we could maybe
kind of build or something maybe like a
quick
um kind of example of of an upcoming
future you guys
have well uh obviously not in this
server but like maybe like something
that could like give us a little
taste we could build a sort of one of
the sort of solar panel recharging
things that we've been uh
conceptualizing for the batteries so
that kind of we could build one of those
um as we're building that anything else
uh you guys want to touch
on uh I think that's all we've got uh I
mean we've got a few more things that
we're going to be working on in the next
like month or two uh a lot of people
have been asking for rails I know a lot
of people in the Clos testing group are
going to be going mental now I've said
that but uh the we're going to be
working on Rails it's just more of a
complicated thing than we anticipated so
we're going to be working on bringing uh
straight rails and curved rails and
stuff so people can build more
mechanical things wow as opposed to uh
what using like the landing gear or like
I've seen so many different ways which
is so cool about this game is even
though there's landing gear people have
managed to you know create some kind of
contraption with landing gear or or
tires and it people just get extremely
creative yeah so it's going to allow
people to build things like that much
more easily rather than sort of um
scrapping things together out of what
they have currently which is good it
shows the creativity of the community
well this on the back of this drill what
was i' I've never seen this in action
what is this new piece it's like an
ejector or
something uh it's both it's ejector and
uh sort of injector sort of thing so if
toas brings it around here we can sort
show you what it does yep that'll be
right there so this is um an example of
the connector block this was about 3
weeks ago we added these um so this is
the large ship connect block that I'm
flying next to here and the small ship
one is Tash is it's on the back of
tash's
ship see now yeah they've connected now
and this provides a power and a um
conveyor connection between the two
ships so you can transfer all the or out
of the drills into the refer stuff yeah
actually right now I have the access uh
to anything that is that is on this um
station just by connecting through this
connector so I can set the turrets or
like start um assembling something or
stop anything like let's say I'll have a
I won't have enough power to assemble
something so I will stop the refinery to
refine ore and so I can save energy and
stuff like that that's awesome yeah as
opposed to you know before we had to
basically um pick up the ore from the
drill and then bring it to a Refinery
this will just immediately do that on
its own that's great I'm pretty sure
that the Refinery will see or in this
inventory of the ship and automatically
draw it to itself and start processing
it so you don't have to do it manually
wow do you want do you want to guys mine
some ore together I can copy paste more
ships so that everyone has a
ship so you guys can hop in and mine
some stuff sounds good to
me and well actually this um charging
batteries will be the same uh if you
will have is on your small ship then
you'll connect it through the connector
to a platform that has let's say bunch
of solar panels and the charging will
start yep so you can have like I don't
know six small shapes and each time you
uh your low on battery you can just set
it to be charged and then take a
different
one and usually the asteroids they have
uh the core is made of iron so it takes
a while to actually get to
it but once you're there you've got
seemingly infinite amount of iron
there's millions of kilograms of iron in
the side of each
asteroid also this ship was designed to
work as a perfect uh Miner which means
that uh the shape of the ship is kind of
it follows the the drills right so when
you make the hole You you you won't be
stopped you can just keep going on you
are through the whole asteroid right
unlike maybe something like this where I
kind of modded it my own way these kind
of sticking out parts will get in the
way if if I'm trying to go all the way
deep yeah that's one of the nice things
about space engineers that um you can
kind of design things that are really
practical rather than uh just look good
so there are both sides you can design
beautiful things but also designs that
actually work perfectly for its purpose
right you need the engineer and the
designer to collaborate exactly the most
athetic um ships probably won't be the
most practical or sort of
um oh usually when you build something
what happened
there oh we got asteroids turned on okay
oh asteroids asteroids so that's what's
going on right now these turrets are oh
they're they're getting it get an AST
some asteroids
here you can't really see them oh
there's one this mode but you can you
can see the red uh targeting reticules
the target the um they're like lasers
yeah yeah the turrets draw around the
asteroids so
tight but if these hit the station or
your ships they will blow a Hole uh
through your station and stuff so oh is
that right yep so they're not the
smartest guys they're they're getting
there
awesome
um what else also well we have several
systems in the game that you can put in
consideration when designing the ship so
there are like cargo containers the
reactors also conveyor system is quite
complex and it's its purpose is to
connect all the the storage areas to
actually move the items around right so
so so that you don't have to have like
let's say several storage places that
you can car that you have to carry items
between them you'll just connect them
with a pipe and then like move the stuff
inside just by pressing a
button so would and that would work as
far as like the piping of that you would
have to rebuild or take like take down
walls or whatever structure you have or
are you saying that you could basically
kind of um connect through other pieces
with the um conveyor
currently you can't connect through all
the pieces if you look at the station or
any of the the driller ships you'll see
that they have a sort of armor layer and
a sort of um how do you say it
infrastructure layer where they've got
the conveyor tubes connected to
conveyors connected to like um storage
containers and connectors and stuff so
that's a sort of infrstructure of your
ship and then you can build the armor
around it to protect it or make it look
um good depending on how you want to
design your ship sure when you usually
design the ship it takes like several
stages so that you design the core and
then all the systems and then you kind
of build the armor level it's not like
that you would build the ship from
scratch without watch over design so it
takes a while it it takes that design
thinking to kind of make it work oh yeah
definitely once again the yeah the
argument between the designer and the
engineer always
it's always going to be there yeah if
you look underneath this platform as
well you can see the conveyors that
connect up the uh turrets and the
reactors and stuff oh totally yeah also
you can see the Grinders that uh can uh
kind of get the items and uh stuff from
ships already made I'll show you how
that works yeah I was just about to ask
it actually okay so I turned them off
through the control panel yeah and now
it's being uh disassembled
that's
awesome it will take a while but um all
all the material that was used for
building the blocks is right now
transferred into the cargo container so
if you open one of these cargo
containers you should be able to see uh
the items being piled up great and that
would be what um where are those guys
going to go put over here
this
uh you can open any uh any control panel
that's right that's small blue thing I
don't think these Grinders are actually
going to work cuz we're in creative mode
so the stuff that they grind is just
just disappears in survival mode the uh
stuff that every single piece that's
gone into that ship can be grinded off
100% efficiency so definitely yeah so
it's going right to the refinery right
now that's
awesome
yeah one big piece is floating
away
wow it's done already a chip is
dunzo oh I actually I just saw this
today I had to look up how to do this
but you can now I don't know if this was
a couple weeks ago you can now change
the color of your uh suit yeah yeah that
was last week was it was it last
week how do you do that again you go t
oh yeah t that's right and you can do
any color to your liking look at that
yep you can also do the same with the
color of blocks by pressing p with the
armor blocks selected
right you get the same sort of
menu well also for players that think
about starting playing the space
engineers we recomend you did that Qui
pink you love that color don't you look
at that what are you saying I'm sorry
well no no that um if players would like
to start playing Space Engineers from
scratch we recommend to watch all the
videos that we have on our Channel
because the update videos they are not
just to show or say that there's
something new but we also explain the
the new features and and the way they
work so we try to like every week we try
to explain all the possible things that
you can do with it and uh like the way
it changed from like let's say uh a few
weeks before and stuff like that so to
kind kind of keeping track of what's new
it's it's better to watch the tuto the
the updates yeah and go through the
videos the way they actually were upd uh
were
uploaded yeah I have to uh even catch up
myself sometimes with like rotors rotors
are like at my point they're they're
very complex and and amazing when people
can like accomplish like gigantic well I
think the other day I saw like someone
made like two sockum Boer robots
like I mean with with with just you know
one simple mechanic that just turns and
they they go to town on that stuff I
mean personally yeah it gets really uh
intimidating but yeah the tutorials are
a a must
Rockets yeah if you come over here to
the um sort of engine room of one of the
ships you can see where a meteor uh
Struck it one of the ones that got
through the Gatling defenses and it blew
a hole in the side of the ship right
next to the reactor oh I see it so if
another one it could have taken out a
reactor reactors are like ridiculously
expensive so you need yeah adequate um
protection from environmental hazards
that is that's some damage right there
so um actually I this was one of my
questions is um weapons there currently
you
got the uh machine gun here mhm you have
any other um weapons in the making maybe
like a rocket launcher or yeah rocket
launcher is right here well there's one
for ships yeah but me like yeah
handheld I said
handheld we have me and toas were
actually speaking about this earlier
about the idea of a handheld rocket
launcher it's not really something that
we have planned like as a team but it's
definitely something we could suggest
like and it should be pretty easy to do
right it basically what the same you
know mechanic of that um yeah launcher
you have there definitely
mhm very
awesome some point we are definitely
going to crash this ship into the uh
station or there's a blue ship there
blue ship over here that you can crash
it into like the starting video you cut
it in half with the big purple one oh
yeah where is that one there's another
one right where is it yeah you can see
it on your hood cuz it's got an antenna
on it it's oh blue too I say up there
but I will build the passenger seat for
you so so we can get there just give me
a second oh oh that's right that's right
uh when did you guys add that I I
haven't used it yet there's a passenger
seat
now yeah it's on the top of the small
ship you guys get there very practical I
Love
It Rock on okay so enjoy the
ride go for
it uh the passenger seats were added
three updates ago yeah
yeah okay so here we
are a little Landing Bay in here yeah
but I'm afraid I will kind of watch the
heads bump your
head yep we are in
awesome
oops Yeah people were asking for sort of
a way to be able to travel around
uh on other people's ships without
having to um give control to the people
that wanting transporting sort of thing
so people can make like I've seen a lot
of people build like uh drop ships and
stuff with like one cockpit and then a
bunch of Passenger seats on the back for
like troops to sit sort of thing if they
were to do like an invasion on an enemy
faction sort of thing that is where I
feel like one of my like dreams of this
game would be some kind of you know drop
ship that could drill a hole into
another enemy ship and just yeah unload
a bunch of guys and then come across
these turrets like that that's just
amazing if it gets there and I'm sure it
well yeah I mean you can that's one of
the things uh with the combat of this
game you can uh it sort of it can bring
out the engineering people rather than
just the um sort of warrior and people
like you can build engineering things
like you said yeah uh sort of drill
through the side of a ship and sort of
take it by hand sort of thing rather
than just blowing it to Pieces another
ship
all right well uh hell let's just crash
this
thing well also in the future well the
first thing will be this update but we
are going to add
antennas and uh right now the antennas
will be able to see just enemy players
and like friendly friendly players but
in the future you'll be able to remotely
connect to like turrets or even other
ships so that's definitely something to
look forward to yeah because then then
you can have a whole crew and one
Captain piloting the ship and then other
people can kind of like take control of
the
turrets definitely make make sure that
they kind of Target the same priority
thing and that can be interesting yeah
and even uh when I was playing last
night I even um a lot of guys in the
chat were even saying like hey I'm a I'm
a pilot slash you know minor you know
people are kind of already like criter
ising themselves of like what kind of
role they want to play yeah I've seen a
few uh groups on Steam setting up with a
sort of um almost like a sort of World
of Warcraft Guild type structure where
they have or even an E online
Corporation type structure where they
build their own um sort
of hierarchy around their faction so
they'll have like um Commander people
that will sort tell everyone else what
to do they'll have like Miners and
pilots and fighter pilots and stuff so
there's a lot of interesting things that
people can do with the factions
definitely hey uh Tomas I think you
should build a passenger seat right up
front for the best view in the
house okay also the this large ship has
rocket launchers in the front so oh it
does g yeah yeah g and sign it oh you're
darn right it
does
yeah so these rocket pods on the front
of large ships I think they have
27 uh rocket pods so they can fire a lot
faster than the ones on small ships can
and aome oh look at that I actually
haven't seen that uh rocket pod yet
you're right and also the advantage is
that compared to small ship you can
actually build the rockets on the large
ship and then put them through the
conveyor lines into the rocket launchers
so as long as you are making the Rockets
fast enough you can just shoot them
infinitely oh
wow have resources on board yeah that's
awesome you also noticed a nice little
thing I noticed about the um rocket PS
is the fact that the Rockets um come out
of each one of the little holes
sequentially so it looks like they're
actually firing
properly trying to get a view
there yeah you're right that's really
cool all right strap
in you definitely have the best seat
right
there Infinity beond remind me of that
Space Cowboys movie you're like Tommy Le
Jones who just straps himself in the
front of the
rocket here we
go maybe I'll move the the small ship
from The
Hanger if I'll make it I think yeah you
locked it down so it move
around
oh I didn't make
it yeah we had a got bit of a
problem only thing that's missing you
know so are you guys working on sound
effects I feel like that's another part
that could really be useful in that
impact yeah you're you're right uh
that's something that we are going to
work at uh but right now it's uh it has
lower priority because we need to make
sure uh or or we need to try or get it
into a stage where it's not going to be
changed yeah so because right now we
kind of make a feature and then then
find out that it needs to be twisted a
bit so we would have to change the sound
as well so yeah I guess that goes for
any kind of production really huh music
always comes later and all that stuff
you're right
yeah um there is actually a video if
you're interested that someone uh made
about 3 or four months ago where they
um took a scene in Space Engineers
removed the default sound and then added
like their own sort of gravity type uh
sound effects and that's we used that
video as a sort of basis for the audio
that we want to add eventually wow
that's cool I like to see
that I go find
that think gu this one
y we also would like to work more on the
modding thing so that players can create
their own blocks and uh
actually make things that they would
like to see in their
worlds and in future it should it should
be supported by Steam Workshop so people
will be able to download the mods from
when joining the server and this way
you'll be able to create like your own
custom skins for astronauts or like I
don't know special specialized blocks
for making the Interiors more
interesting so yeah we will put more uh
effort into learning or actually
teaching the community how to build
these models and the mechanics of the
game so that they can shape the game the
way they want awesome well so going to
working on a system of um in-game block
programming so you can uh program blocks
like uh thrusters and stuff to do
certain things so you could build like
tell thrusters to fire at certain points
to make something move somewhere
or I'm not really sure how it's going to
work uh as a system but you'll basic
I've been told you'll be able to make um
blocks that have command to do pretty
much anything you want so we're going to
be adding a system of uh sensors as well
so you can uh get inputs from the game
world and use that to
modify outputs in the
blocks
wow so do you want to guys try to build
something like a small ship why not yeah
let's do like a small ship some guns on
it so where do you want to meet um
platform somewhere like did this
platform like level differently because
that crash oh never mind no no no it's
it's a station uh and with the station
status it it can't move I thought sh
something yeah never mind
all right let's
build well the reason um it's a bit
angled is because there are two gravity
generators right now and the second one
is slightly angled yeah the gravity
fields are sort of interfering with each
other yeah exactly uh speaking of
gravity that run was fun speaking of uh
gravity generators
um I was thinking the other day I
haven't built like a car yet I know you
you guys add whoa like steering wheel
would that be uh possible to do right
now uh yeah you can do actually build
that I'll make a bigger platform over
here um so one yeah go ahead the big the
big thing we made um last the big thing
we in last update oops it's B pink uh
was the addition of the steering wheels
right so you can create um wheels that
are actually controlled by W and
D sort of thing so you can make uh cars
and stuff uh
a lot more
realistic there go the
turrets was the idea I mean I'm sure the
idea was just to make Wheels in general
oh wheel did you guys change the wheels
recently uh yeah this this is different
type you you have uh like Single wheels
and these are more advanced they have
the suspension stuff and they are
controlled by uh um the keys on your
keyboard so you don't have to go to
control panel and stuff oh that's
awesome but it it takes a lot of
practice to actually balance the cars so
that they work well on the surface yeah
because
um the gravity is always different and
everything depends on the amount of uh
artificial Mass cubes you have which is
basically a block that is affected by
gravity and there is nothing else well
actually the player these Mass cubes
items and it's about it uh all these
things are affected by gravity but
nothing else because um it would be too
hard to build anything like let's say if
a small ship was affected by gravity
then it would be pretty hard to actually
land somewhere because then you could
place like like six gravity generators
there and the ship would just Slam
against the ground so we decided to kind
of take that off yeah it's more of a a
game play um absolutely decision rather
than uh sort of realistic physics type
thing yeah oh okay I need more MC yeah
that's awesome yeah uh last time I was
um messing with the wheels someone I
someone had made like the aliens draw uh
um troop transport it was pretty cool
but yeah it would just slide around the
wheels weren't working at
all yeah that's why we added these uh
but before you had to use the rotors uh
and actual wheels and then use thrusters
to move them
around well I uh I think the the uh
server should ride the car oh yeah
they're a bit uh bit of a work in
progress for the client client servers
but it runs super smooth if you're the
server host I have to
sign uh I think it should have be set up
so you just use W and D to move around
I'm doing that right
now doesn't work no it's not working do
we are we missing are we missing
something uh let me think well as Adam
said it's still work in progress so
maybe it worked for me so no I and I
noticed that actually let me try oh okay
parking breake maybe Park brakes on or
something like that it's true there are
brakes
um oh there we go uh I think the cockpit
hadn't been so there it is yeah the in
the cockpit if you go into the control
panel you have to set the settings for
uh Wheels to be controlled and turn the
control for thrusters off so
panel what do I go in the control panel
uh press go in the control panel and
then go to uh find the cockpit and
you'll see an option just to do oh
control Wheels yeah actually joking I
didn't know there actually was a
handbrake function yeah if you if you
press p p is the hand bre oh this is
great you said u p was hbre yeah p is
the handbreak like the landing gear so
if you press P you
should oh
yeah no oh
no I think you got outside the gravity
range though oh
God that
helped well I'll see you guys
later we can try to save it actually uh
just let me try something I'll face the
car and no that's just a trash okay I
have to oh man I got real far away I
think we we're gonna have to ditch that
car see you dude if you uh leave the car
and point at it with with a block and
just press contrl C you'll copy it and
when you get back to the platform you
can press contrl V and you you add the
car to the platform we should do another
car though that that car that car is
long gone okay it didn't have any
thrusters on so it would just fall
indefinitely
cuz that was that was a little scary I'm
not going to lie
there were there are so many times where
I've just been laughing in tears when I
see some guy in chat who's
like help me guys help me I'm I'm
falling someone come rescue me and he
sees his like K kilometers like his
meter just flying up like he's just gone
in a ship
oops uh something happened yeah I just I
I accidentally uh cut the um station
okay so can you paste it back I can't
stick it back in the right place still
have to go over there things are not
going well right now oh there it is oops
that's the power of copy paste you can
ruin someone's day very quickly uh I'll
move the large chip so that we have some
sunlight how do you do uh copy and paste
uh just look at something contrl V and
contrl C like you would in any other uh
thing moft Bas
stuff and oh well we would let actually
like to mention that uh Community helps
us helps us like a great deal because
they they build like awesome stuff and
they are a big inspiration for us yeah
we do go through literally every uh
comment on a YouTube video or a Facebook
post that we do and we take notes uh of
everything that the community wants and
then we work on the stuff that they want
so also all the stuff that we've added
recently was uh voted for in a community
commity vote that we had so we're sort
of going through that uh adding things
that people want sequentially
sweet we every time we see some
suggestion we kind of think about uh if
it's possible to actually make it to the
game because the game uh has mechanics
that can be kind of like changed or
Twisted sometimes sometimes they can but
sometimes that would just break many
other things so uh we kind of have to
make decision on what what can be done
and what can't and then then we also
think about how much time it would
take and some features can be done
pretty quickly because they have some
similar feature already in the game so
for example uh the small ship rocket
launcher was made quite early but for
the large ship it took quite quite some
time to make it but it was all already
in the game so it didn't take that much
time to edit there yeah and I I actually
think that one of the players made it
even before us yeah someone uh modded
the uh small weapons onto a large ship
and that's kind of what gave us our
inspiration to add it to the base game
that's really cool you guys always let
them know or like say I mean I'm sure
you do like respond to them be like hey
congratulations you just got
Incorporated yeah we we always we try to
communicate with the uh fans as much as
we can yeah and let know that the stuff
that they're suggesting isn't just going
to waste we are actually listening
oh yeah somebody actually explained it
quite nicely and the the person said
that we are answering in in
updates that yeah players make
suggestions and then we answer in that
update whether it's going to be made or
not that's awesome all right I'll set
this car up for
you all right the car should be ready to
go now I still want to try this copy and
paste thing do I have to like if I
wanted to copy and paste this entire car
mhm I just do I look at it and I do
control V or control C I think you have
to have a block selected build okay then
that's what I'm doing wrong I got you're
right you can have multiple cards uh
this is another thing that was added
recently which means that you can copy
paste the whole car sick that that was
not possible before because the the
rotors are
quite uh well quite complex yeah and uh
complex yeah yeah and basically the car
is made from uh multiple GDs and it took
a while to actually find a way to kind
of put them together to to be able to
copy them and P them somewhere El yeah
it was a lot more difficult than it
seemed to make uh them work but we made
it work
eventually who's ring got Hydraulics
nothing it's a little bit glitchy for
the clients on a server like I said it's
still work in progress so he looks he
looks pretty happy in my
opinion or it tries to get the Adam out
of the
cockpit
behave the rors were always kind of
difficult for multiplayer but yeah it's
something that we're working on to sort
of resolve as you can see it's not
really playable at the moment cuz this
car won't stop
moving I was if you get in a car it
should be fine it should just work
perfectly I always thought um I don't
know if you guys were probably I imagine
maybe you even have thought of it but
like hot keying um certain uh
rotors yeah that's something that's
going to come with the block program we
talked about you're going to be able to
assign certain commands or certain
blocks to uh hot Keys oh my car's
falling off the world you going to able
to assign stuff to certain hot keys so
you can assign like I said thrusters or
certain weapon groups to the
toolbar
yeah yeah I hate that card
too oh this is
great and I want to see some uh like
mining Rovers on an asteroid if you so
if you put like a a gravity gen
generator
on on the Rover could it would it be
able to successfully like drive around
on an
asteroid uh the small ships can't have
their own gravity at the moment but you
can I'll bring I've copied the thing
I'll bring it over to the asterid and
I'll show you
okay I think there's a gravity field
here put it there then you have to have
a station or a large ship nearby to
provide the gravity cuz we thought that
the it wouldn't make much sense if um
like gravity generators something of
fiction so we want to try and keep them
as quite limited it's there only for
gameplay purposes really because you
won't be able to move around in ships
with
that but you can have a lot of fun with
the gravity gener generators I've seen
like many crazy ideas
about uh unknown flying objects made by
rotating rotating uh gravity
fields and they would make these uh
small ships orar chips fly like crazy
and nobody would actually drive
them them go made do a little bridge
over to the
as again it's it's really inspiring to
see what community builds with in the
game it's like amazing yeah yeah I
personally watch the screenshots on
YouTube every day when I when I leave
the work so yeah kinds
of no it is incredible and the I
remember well I did uh I did a feature
on this game a while ago and it was B
basically me stumbling into a star wars
server and it was just I was blown away
every time and and these kids were so
funny they're like oh no we have more
and it just kept escalating to the point
where this it was the mass
relay mhm from Mass Effect and that was
beyond me how they got that thing to
operate yeah it's pretty cool so I've
built you a ship up here on this
asteroid you can see I mean this
asteroid is more of a sphere so there
isn't really that much uh space to drive
around sure
but there are some asteroids that are
much flatter than this I think there's
one in this map actually also if you
would like to paint your car we can tell
you how to do it oh yeah uh you I know
you pull out the
cube yeah and it's with a middle Mouse
button uh no uh press p and select the
color you want you want the same system
I like but
uh yeah yeah you can
uh also not many people know but you can
hold down shift and control and that
will give you different brush sizes for
painting stuff so like I think uh if you
hold down shift it's a uh three radius
brush and control is a two radius brush
so you can paint things much
faster shift
control you can press either shift or
control I got you yeah you're right
shift is the largest uh largest brush
yep that's a three radius awesome Green
Machine this is
great so theoretically I have made a
couple of things like this before been
testing stuff out you can stick like a
uh oh
crap uh like a drill in the front and
then you can use it as a drilling thing
H it's there should be worth
it should
work oh I select it there we
go oh
yeah
wheelie well I can try to help you
up I think it's cuz it's a bit uh back
heavy because of the way the drill is
let me just add a bit of weight to the
front there you go best there it
is
just a little just a little snip here oh
here we
go looks like a John oh
no um I can try to help a little bit
upside down there a it's
perfect yeah come a little push there
push push here we go oh that broke your
ship
yeah I can try to pick you up if you
turn off of the the mass blocks in
control panel which blocks the
artificial Mass blocks artificial
yep oh thank
you give it a shot
now
fine it's like you're too
heavy what are you trying to
say oh here we go almost think is just
bit wedged shoot okay I broke my I think
that was partly my fault it helped I
think you've actually got have you got a
MK block no you haven't okay you are
just floating into the IIs
now it's really hard to catch
you maybe try the uh the
underbelly uhoh I think you here we
go
does want doesn't want to
snap sorry we'll just keep pushing you
around eventually sounds great I'm
having fun oh no what happened I think
that was me I think you I think you shot
me I think I maybe I think one of those
guns were uh facing a block um but yeah
that that's done that is a finished
vehicle oh yep screw that it's
gone we have two more cars over
there plenty
more so can I I can copy this whole ship
right here huh yep you can also another
thing we added was the ability to um
make stations into ships like the
stations are what they are they are
stationary hence the name but we added a
function where you could go into the
control panel and set a station to
actually be able to move so if I go into
this control panel
uh if you go into the info tab there's a
little option that says convert to
ship because a lot of people what
they've been doing was they've been
building for hours and hours and hours
but they've been building
stations and they've been building it as
a ship so when they came to test that
ship I've done that once yeah yeah they
couldn't actually move
it yeah you feel you you feel pretty
dumb
but also also we have that uh mirroring
feature that allows you to build ships
much faster like if you start a small
ship uh then you can set the planes U
just give me a second yeah planes like
this and everything that you build will
get mirrored on the other
side that's
right it's much faster to build anything
this way
right oh Adam is flying with the station
I'm in a little bit of
trouble cars are weighing me down
slightly what a be let's just just get
rid of that but we don't need
that and well for a ship uh you need
several important components uh one of
them is to have thrusters for each side
and then you need
gyroscope and
reactor yeah that's something I don't
have I don't have JCS in this that's why
it's moving yeah and this is fully
operational ship right now small but
working
C you have I was thinking about last
night have you guys um considered like
matchmaking maybe some game types like
capture capture flag or something like
that CU I know there's some maps already
there like kind of like two base setups
mhm you guys we were talking about this
earlier again actually is something that
we think people should be able to do
with the uh in Block the in-game block
programming yeah so I don't know if
we're going to be add a function to be
able to bring up things on the hood so
like a scoreboard or something but right
something that we should be able to do
eventually yeah um I also got uh
information that we will be working on
scenarios that will actually have a
purpose so people will have to kind of
they will have some Mission or Reason to
play this play the scenarios so that
will be something to look forward in the
future yeah so friends could join a
world and try to like
uh finish the goal stuff like
that this is a terrifying visual right
here look at
that oh small ships are being crushed
like an aircraft
carrier yeah one of the funny things I
saw was the uh easy start to uh where
someone uh made it into a ship and was
flying this giant space station that
looks like it should be attached to a um
a station an asteroid sorry and they're
just flying it around as an actual ship
that was kind of
cool so have um I haven't se I haven't
really tested out any like workshops
lately of like I don't know sometimes i'
I've loaded a workshop in the past like
U someone tried to make a death star and
it just froze my computer have have um
there have been a lot of improvements on
like just size and scale and and CPU
handling and all that uh optimization is
one of the things we work on nearly
every single week that'll always be a
little subnote at the bottom of the main
releases that will say we've uh
optimized certain things and I think
this week we've actually um in the dev
testing Branch at the moment there's
quite a big optimization change to the
rendering engine so when things aren't
being looked at they're not rendered so
you can play on worlds with big things
in them and have a much higher FPS so we
are constantly working on optimizing the
game also uh there will be a lot of uh
optimization in models itself
because right now
um they don't really have that many LOD
models so what you see is actually what
you got yeah so but in the future they
should change so that it's less harder
on on
performance so but that's also one of
the things that people could take in in
consideration when designing things for
Workshop that they actually will try to
design ships that are easy on
performance as well yeah I mean someone
in the uh testing group made a sort of
one for one I think it was one for one
replica of uh I think it's Stargate
Atlantis and like no one's computer can
handle that not even computer it crashes
them straight away so we're trying to
optimize as much as possible well it's
it's not a bad thing it it looks amazing
and everything but it's just for many
people it's hard to play with it yeah
yeah
I also uh saw
a a mod that will allow to edit the
models themselves that they have way
lower number of triangles so that way
you are able to actually build even
larger ships than than you would be able
to do wow because because the blocks are
are I don't know if it goes down by 200%
or how much I can't remember but I know
what you're about so then you can build
like miles
of uh
ship construction without a
problem you you can't really see from
distance that it's uh that the triangles
were taken out
but it looks pretty
cool um what was I G to say oh um the
other day I was looking at a server and
it was talking
about just like info and how they they
do like for dedicated servers they do
like
cleanup how does that actually work I
was I just was curious about how that
how
they they just hunt down all the random
stuff and just and just kind of wipe it
clean I think it works on a sort of
algorithm where it looks at what
actually makes up the trash comment and
so if it's got like a cockpit or if it's
got a certain amount of thrusters or if
it's just like a random piece of armor
that's floating around indefinitely into
the abyss then that sort of stuff will
be uh cleaned up but people's ships that
are actually sort of stationary sitting
still somewhere they won't be deleted
but all the sort of debris from battles
and things I you can see a few pieces
floating around that we've already
generated there is also a specific
definition for for these blocks or
anything that floats around that will be
deleted after some time so yeah yeah
also we had to add a feature that will
remove the the respawn ships because
people would would be joining the game
but then leaving leaving right away
right y yeah yeah when we they gone what
when we
first when we first started
um the uh multiplayer they' just be like
like a sea of orang yellow ships
everywhere yeah I remember I remember
that it was great actually CU if you
were doing survival mode you just
scavenge those ships and not even have
to mind yeah exactly so we worked on the
system of getting rid of
those makes people's lives harder but
makes the game fairer let's let's try
one of these
Warheads yeah that's
fun Al well it's fun if you uh combine
them with copy pasting then you can play
something like a
baseball just throw uh the WarHeads oh
do that let's do that yeah I can show
you if I'll find you oh here you are
okay so build um like new large
ship and place the landing gear anywhere
and then oh build a new one okay yeah
yeah because you need the the Warhead
itself just just one just one and press
C
and if
you how to call it if you drag the mouse
and press oh just left M but yeah left
Mouse button you have to copy the
Warhead and basically just swing your
character around and press paste at the
same time and you'll sort of throw uh oh
he'll throw Warheads around make quite a
mess yeah that's what people actually
doing a lot with gravity generators that
they would build all types of like
Warheads being pushed by gravity
Fields yeah they can be like one Warhead
can make a big hole in any ship so yeah
yeah something people have been trying
to do is build like um sort of proximity
mines so you'd have a warhead with a GRA
with a sort of artificial Mass block on
it so when a ship would come nearby If
the gravity was in the right direction
the Warhead we sort of pulled towards
the ship and would make a mess of
things it's it's really amazing what all
can like players come up with
yeah like one of the cool was that giant
um like rail
gun um so I remember someone was showing
me on a server once which was how did
that even work again it was just turning
off and on a gravity generator
basically yeah so what you can do with
the gravity generators is if you go into
the control panel you can uh set the
sort of field width depth and height so
you can make like a column of gravity so
to speak and you can use that as sort of
a launch um sort of a barrel sort of
thing the propulsion for a sort of
projectile if you will uh can you can
you find me I can show you on on my
position do you me no okay do you see me
oh yeah so let's say that I'll build
um reactor and next to this place I'll
build anything like new grit and the
mass
Cube again you need a reactor for that
because the okay it flew
away see you so that means there was a
gravity field in this area so so if you
point the the gravity generators in the
correct um in the correct direction then
the mass cutees will fall that way yeah
in the past people would use items to
actually uh make these uh what is it
called propostion systems that they
would put landing gears in front of
their ships and attach a large item to
the to it and then use the gravity
fields to actually move the ship toward
yeah sort of infinitely scaling
propulsion system sort of thing like so
you basically use Mass to in a gravity
field created by your ship to pull your
ship along so I thing that's also we
could show you the the merge blocks
these are quite important and
interesting and new yeah and you uh let
me uh ad my for your ship okay that's
fine so the main thing about the merge
blocks is actually that you can connect
two GDs together and in the past it was
not possible to do it
because well there was just no support
for it so if you had a l uh if you had a
large ship and you would break it apart
into two pieces you would have to choose
the bigger one and then just rebuild it
completely but now you can build these
merge blocks and if you put them close
uh close enough they will
connect and I'll try to show
you do you see the merge block
yep okay so oh this one
gotcha so I'll try
to get pretty close yeah see look at
that
automatically yep okay so oh go ahead
then these the two ships that are now
connected are now um to the game they
are now one ship so it's sort of a
official connection between the two we
call them grids but we actually mean
ships yeah ships that is really cool
look at that thing right now I'm right
now I'm moving the whole platform if you
notice yeah so trying
the power and um control of the ship but
not the sort of item movement that you
can do with the other
connectors I can also decide to break
the connection by turning off one of the
merge
blocks and then I break free see
yeah that's for like docking ships or
yeah just moving around entire platforms
perfect yeah if you want to dark um
like a lot well not a lot but like
strong connection you would you would
use the merge blocks but you can do the
same with the
connectors and through the connectors
you can also connect small ship to large
ship which also was not possible before
yeah well guys this has been absolutely
awesome um thank you so much for taking
the time to show me all this great new
add-ons for this game I you know very
very look U very much looking forward to
the future
um but yeah thanks so much uh toas lead
art of our lead artist of the space of
lead art artist of uh space engineers
and um Adam thank you guys so much le
arst as
well thank you it's been a pleasure
thank you for having us oh yeah thank
you man all right well that has been
Space Engineers thank you guys so much
for watching um again this this is the
fourth top selling game on Steam you can
pick up for about $20 and um it's a
blast it gets better every week and
that's it for this week see you guys
next time goodbye by
bye